course the ripples of what is going on  in ukraine reaching out  far and wide including into the world of  sport we've just received a statement  from formula one  concerning the russian grand prix which  was due to be held towards the end of  september  it says the fia formula one world  championship visits countries all over  the world with a positive vision to  unite people bringing nations together  we are watching the developments in  ukraine with sadness and shock and hope  for a swift and peaceful resolution to  the present situation on thursday  evening so this was last night formula  one the fia and the teams discuss the  position of our sport and the conclusion  is including the view of all relevant  stakeholders that it is impossible to  hold the russian grand prix  in the current circumstances so the  russian grumpy grand prix supposed to  take place on the 23rd of september that  weekend it's not happening